why our I beams shaped like an eye have
you ever actually taken a moment to
think about this this simple technology
forms the basis of all our largest
structures and even features in one of
the world's most famous photos but after
asking some of my friends if you
actually knew the answer to this simple
question the i-beam is designed in that
way to handle a maximum bending load
while using the least amount of material
let's look at an i-beam supported on
either end to understand more when we
apply a uniform load across this beam
the max deflection will occur here in
the middle we can calculate the
deflection with this equation this may
look complicated but it really isn't W
represents the uniformly distributed
load in terms of Newtons per meter L is
the span between supports e is the
Youngs modulus which as explained in my
material properties on a one video
describes the stiffness of the material
but the variable we want to focus on is
I which represents the second moment of
area sometimes called the moment area of
inertia this describes the shape of the
beam more specifically it describes how
the material is distributed throughout
the shape these two shapes have the same
area but that area is distributed very
differently and that is very important
as sea salt is a good analogy for this
idea when we place weight in the middle
it is very easy to lift in fact if we
place it exactly over the middle we
aren't lifting it at all but the further
we move that weight to the end the more
difficult it is to lift due to the
increasing leverage a very similar thing
happens with beams and bending material
at the center of the beam which is
called the neutral axis does not resist
bending and the material furthest away
from the center resist bending the most
it is called the neutral axis because if
we place a bending load downward the
same way we did before the beam will
Bend in a way that will cause the lower
edge to be in max tension and the upper
edge to be in max compression and the
values of stress gradually decrease to
zero at the neutral axis where there is
neither tension or compression because
the tension and compression is maximum
the furthest from the neutral axis we
want to maximize the amount of material
on the outside of the profile where it
is needed most the more material further
from the neutral axis the larger the
second moment of area will be applying
that to the equation we can see that a
larger second moment of area will result
in a smaller deflection so if we place
this section under the same bending mode
it would actually be stronger if we
flipped it over 90 degrees because now
more material is located further from
the neutral axis we could make it even
stronger again by reducing this
thickness to a minimum just enough to
resist the shear stress and placing that
material at the top and suddenly we're
back to the i-beam shape you can see
this idea put into action all around you
in my last video I mentioned just one of
them when I spoke about the Willis Tower
using a bundled tube structure this
structure maximizes the amount of steel
on the outside of the building to
maximize its resistance to lateral
bending from wind and other loads I will
be talking about another application of
this technology in my next video and if
you can think of any other examples of
the second moment of area being applied
in the world around you be sure to share
it in the comments thanks for watching
like my last video I wanted to
experiment with a shorter format and
it's thanks to sponsors like the great
courses plus that allow me the freedom
to do that they've been a fantastic
sponsor of this channel over the last
few months if you'd like to learn more
about subjects like this they have a
great course called everyday engineering
and they have a huge range of other
topics too their courses give you
in-depth knowledge and are thought by
world-renowned educators they added a
new course from Neil deGrasse Tyson
recently or you can learn about
photography history or cooking if you'd
like to learn more head over to the gray
course plus Ford slash real engineering
for your free 1:1 trial if you'd like to
see more content from me
the links from my patreon Instagram
Facebook and Twitter accounts are below
you